une de plus si tu te retrouves derrière
les barreaux Flora trouver lui quelque
chose à faire quelque chose qui lui
passera l'envie de chattarder qu'est-ce
que tu es en train de faire tu veux pas
savoir
tu es une très bonne merde tu le penses
joyeux anniversaire c'est quoi passer à
toi j'ai pas envie d'en jouer depuis
quand je suis guitariste tu peux pas
rester les bras croisés vivre dans un
trou haras avec un gosse qui me déteste
vivement le jour où je serai plus obligé
de venir
retourne chez ton père je vais peut-être
apprendre la guitare toute seule ça
demande des années pratique de
l'engagement tu te crois bien placé pour
m'expliquer ce que c'est que
l'engagement
[Musique]
il va vous montrer comment prendre son
panard à la guitare
[Musique]
donc tu vas apprendre la guitare c'est
un cadeau que tu vas emporter dans ta
tombe
la guitare en ligne chérie
dans une
heure
ou quoi baisse moi le son tout de suite
c'est ta musique comment tu as fait ça
c'est énorme
James
tu peux l'essayer elle est trop grande
c'est le style
tu ressembles à une tortue
il faut qu'elle entende ta passion
exprime toi là
elle a détesté je veux juste que tu me
foutes la paix avec
Pétain je me suis retrouvé avec un môme
sur les bras je peux pas me contenter de
cette histoire là
sans lui je me retrouve sans rien
comment tu expliques que quoi que tu
fasses ça suffit jamais
suffit
[Musique]
jouer de la guitare je trouve ça
tellement sexy toi c'est pour ça que tu
as appris
tu es en train de faire avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]